The death of a young Iranian woman
in police custody has sparked weeks
of violent protest in Iran and around the
world. The UN and independent human rights
groups have accused Iranian security forces
of brutal suppression. Where does that leave
attempts to re-start the 2015 nuclear deal,
which the US says is no longer their focus.
Mohammad Marandi, professor at Tehran
University and political analyst:
“We all know that the whole process
is politicized but the Iranians are
more than willing to solve the issue if the
Americans are determined to have a deal.”
Dr Marandi blames the West and NATO for
aggravating the protests and a whole
catalogue of aggression against Iran and other
countries in the region. And as Tehran denies
supplying drones to Moscow - whose side
does he take in the Ukraine/Russia war?
Mohammad Marandi, welcome to Conflict Zone. A
couple of weeks ago you tried to minimize the
importance of the whole protest movement in Iran.
You said it had "died down after three or four
days." That wasn't true, was it? Because two days
ago and six weeks since they began the protests
were reported in at least seven cities, including
Mashhad, Arak, Zahedan, Mahabad and parts of
Tehran. They're not dying down at all, are they?
No, I didn't try to do anything. I said the truth.
The protests in the first couple of days were
larger and they were in different cities. And
they were — partially, because Persian-language
media in London mostly, but also in other Western
countries, lied at the very beginning, and they
claimed that the young lady, Mahsa, was beaten
to death. And so many people thought that this was
a case of police brutality. I- but I also thought
that that may have been the case. But then later
on — later on, the footage came out and it showed
that she had left the police van. She wasn't
even handcuffed. She wasn't holding her head.
She didn't show any signs of physical pain. She
went into a hall and sat there. And after a while,
she stood up, spoke to someone and then suddenly
collapsed. The autopsy showed, there are many
physicians involved, that there was no physical
abuse. And even there's a clip of her father,
beside her body, where he said
that there is no sign of abuse. So
Persian-language media funded by
Western governments and the Saudis,
many of them based in London, were provoking the
Iranian public. But after a few days, the protests
died down. But then we had the rise of very
violent riots. And that's exactly what I said.
Well, let's talk about the violence in
the riots. The UN committee has had — UN
Committee on the Rights of the Child — has had
plenty to say about that. It strongly condemned
what it called "grave violations of children's
rights in Iran." According to reliable reports,
it says some children were "shot with
live ammunition. Others died as a result
of beatings. Many families reported that
despite grieving for the loss of a child,
they were pressured to absolve security forces by
declaring their children had committed suicide and
making false confessions." That's a pretty sick
tactic for your government to employ, isn't it?
No, that's a pretty sick tactic for the
Western media and any institutions that are
under the influence of the Western media to use.
We're talking about the UN Committee on the Rights
of the Child. We're talking about a UN committee.
We're talking about a UN committee reporting that.
Let's not - let - Tim, let's not talk about any
UN committee. Let's talk about the UN and how they
put the Saudis on a blacklist and remove them 72
hours later. The UN has no credibility here. And
this is, this is fake. The claims - I've tweeted
about this - the number of police officers that
were murdered over the last few weeks - at the
instigation of media based in your countries -
they are roughly 28 or 29. Some of them were
shot with guns. Don't talk - let's not talk
about fake news. All these children being killed
all over the place. That's nonsense. Show me the
footage of these children being killed…
Why is it nonsense?
…Instead of these organizations that
are funded by the United States.
Why? Why is it nonsense? Here's an
organization that...
Why is it nonsense?
Because it's your government that's...
Here's an organization that won't be funded
by the United States. This last weekend, the
Coordinating Council of Teachers in Iran called
for a nationwide strike to protest the crackdown
on children. That same teachers' organization said
plainclothes police attacked the Shahid School
in the northwest Ardabil province. Ten pupils
were injured badly enough to be hospitalized.
Parents of the children were also attacked.
You really think that your government going
after children and killing unknown numbers of
demonstrators is going to stop this unrest?
So you're withdrawing the fake claim...
I'm not withdrawing any claim.
...that a young girl was killed
at that school, right?
Right. I'm not withdrawing
any claim because I didn't make any claim.
…because the claim in the Western media,
the claim in the Western media, the filthy
claim in the Western media and the filthy
claim in the Persian-language media funded by your
governments, your government, was that a girl was
murdered at that school. And then it turned out
that that girl didn't even go to that school and
she died because of a family tragedy. But your
governments and those Iranian organizations or
so-called Iranian organizations funded by your
governments in the West make such fake claims so
that the global public opinion would turn against
Iran. And they make those claims in Iran because
you have more Persian-language media directed
towards Iranians than the Iranian government
has. So when your MEK terrorist organization,
that's based in Europe and has a huge camp in
Albania with thousands of people being— acting
as trolls there, they — these people, they
fought alongside Saddam Hussein against their own
country, they killed 17,000 Iranians during the
1980s through assassination attacks, through bomb
attacks. These are the people who are spreading…
…Dr. Marandi…
...fake news alongside the monarchists...
… and other
organizations that are funded by your governments!
I notice you don't want to address the violence,
the violence which, and the brutality of some of
your security forces. Amnesty International...
Of course, I'm fine with addressing...
Amnesty International has reported widespread
torture, severe beatings of protesters and
onlookers, even sexual violence against women
by your security forces. You think the people will
forgive their leaders for this shocking brutality?
No, people will not forgive
your leaders for interfering
in our internal affairs and for...
It's always someone else's fault,
isn't it? It's always someone else's...
…for using Persian-language media. I'm speaking,
Tim. I'm speaking. Don't try to run out the clock.
So it's your Persian-language media and your troll
farms and your governments that are spreading
misinformation both in Persian and in English
across the globe. The police officers that
were killed in Iran, 28 or 29 police officers,
as far as I know during that period, were killed.
People who were policing the streets. If such
numbers were killed in your country, what would
be the response of your government? But what
your Persian-language media was doing during
this period was encouraging people, rioters,
to attack the police, to get revenge, as they
called it, on police. They were telling people to
make Molotov cocktails. If Ofcom, if this — if any
of this was in English and if it was directed to
an English audience, Ofcom would shut down those
TV stations within minutes. But in your case, you
can use it against Iran because your governments
are waging war against the Iranian people. Your
governments don't give a damn about human rights.
Your governments are the ones who impose maximum
pressure on women and children in this country
and try to starve them to death and then use media
warfare against the country to create divisions.
Dr. Marandi, Dr. Marandi, talk of running out
the clock. I've given you a couple of minutes.
Two, three minutes. Isn't it time to face facts
that Iranians and a lot...
You're interviewing me.
…Iranians are angry at your government. The head
of Iran's semi-official ISPA Polling Centre, Mehdi
Behabadi, says a considerable majority of Iranians
harbor anger towards the Islamic Republic,
a factor, he says, which is at a dangerous level.
"Every time there have been widespread protests,
they subside only superficially while the
anger piles up." None of this is going away,
is it? None of this is going away.
And you say it's all the West's fault.
Come on, Tim. We have, we have many polling
institutions in Iran and Western polling
institutions, and the popular legitimacy of the
Islamic Republic of Iran is second to none in
this region. Your despotic allies in this region
tell more than enough about your governments.
In Iran just three years ago, less
than three years ago, after your
leader, your — the leader of the so-called free
world, murdered General Soleimani, we saw how
many millions of people went to the streets
in Tehran. So let's not pretend that the truth
is anything that it is [sic]. Let's, let's speak
facts. Of course, there's dissatisfaction in Iran.
There's always dissatisfaction, dissatisfaction in
Iran. You can go in a taxi. Now — five years ago,
ten years ago, you can spend your time in Tehran.
That's exactly the fact. It shows the fact that
in Iran, people can speak their minds. But
can they do that in Saudi Arabia? Can they
do that in many other parts of the world? Can
people like me — to easily do that and get a
job in your government, in your country?
Why do you keep putting it out? Why do
you play the what about game? What about in
Britain? What about Saudi Arabia? Why don't
we just stay with Iran? Is that so difficult?
Now I'm talking about you. I'm talking about you…
Yeah, and I'm talking about you. We're
not here to discuss me, or the West.
…because you work for a government
that used chemical weapons —No, we are.
I don’t work for a government.
Oh, yes we are. Because you have no credibility.
You do — You work for — the German
government funds your channel. The German
government gassed Iranians.
You think Iran has...?
The German government gassed
me twice. So don't talk...
You think Iran has credibility on
the international stage? Really?
These protests that you said died down have now
spread to the cultural elite. They've spread to
actors, broadcasters, singers…
Tim, you're not in our league.
… sporting stars, people who are admired,
followed and have nothing to do with politics.
Tim, you're not in our league.
Were all these people bought
up and incited by the West?
Tim, you're not in our league. You're not in
our league. Don't run out the clock, Tim. You're
not in our league. Your government, the government
that funds you, that gives you the opportunities
to speak to me, your government gassed me twice.
Where, where were you? You were working at the
BBC back then. You were in your thirties when I
was gassed twice. Where were you when they were
gassing? Don't talk about credibility. You don't
have credibility. Your television station
doesn't have credibility. Your government
doesn't have credibility and the European Union
doesn't have credibility. So don't talk down to
Iran. You — like Josep Borrell, you take care
of your garden and we'll live in our jungle.
You're entitled to your views, Dr. Marandi.
But even among your own politicians,
we're seeing the first signs of open dissent
over the government's methods with these
demonstrations. Former Speaker of Parliament
Ali Larijani questioning the use of force,
saying the police should not be used to encourage
the wearing of the hijab. He's calling for a
"cultural solution." Iranian society, he said,
needs more tolerance. Don't you agree with that?
So you're admitting that in Iran we have open
debate. So you're admitting that we have all
sorts of voices in Iran. So you're admitting that
we have different people who argue with Iran and
fight with each other in parliament, outside of
parliament, in government, at universities. Yes,
that is a part of Iran and that has always been a
part of Iran, post-revolution. Not pre-revolution,
when your guys were in charge, but
post-revolution. In fact, and this is
something that will continue, but you can continue
as you have been, as your colleagues have been,
as Western media has been saying for the last four
years, that the Islamic Republic of Iran is about
to implode. It is corrupt, it is unpopular,
people hate it. It's collapsing. Of course,
Iran — And paradoxically, it's also a growing
menace. I don't know how you can have both at the
same time, where on the one hand it's unpopular,
it's hated and it's collapsing, but on the
other hand it's a growing menace and a growing
threat to the world. But for four decades now,
Iran has been about to collapse. And I think
for the next four decades, we're going to
be hearing the same wishful thinking in the
Western media and Western think tanks again.
Well, let me try putting the question again.
Don't you think Iranian society needs more
tolerance? It's that simple. Can I have an answer?
Iranian society, Iranian society always needs
more tolerance. Iranian society needs better
government management. Iranian society always
deserves better. And that's what we have to strive
to do. And so does your society. And your society
needs more tolerance. And your society should
show — and your government should show a bit of
humility and apologize for the crimes that it has
committed to my people. And people like yourself
should show more tolerance and have a more open
mind about those of us who live in the jungle…
Oh, please.
...As Borrell says.
Oh, please don't take the moral
high ground when your government is
supporting Bashar al-Assad in Syria...
Oh, I have the moral high ground...
...One of the biggest killers and torturers in
the Middle East. Please don't. Please, please,
please don't take the moral high ground,
Dr. Marandi. I think you'll find that's
difficult. Your Revolutionary Guard…
Oh, I will. Oh, I will when you...
…Your Revolutionary Guard dismisses...
Don't run out the clock.
Could I put a question to you? Could I
put a question to you? Your Revolutionary
Guard dismisses...
You already did.
...all the protests as "sedition." Major
General Hossein Salami. “The sedition will
be a stillborn baby and will go down in
history as a disgrace for America.” How
helpful do you think that is in trying to
address legitimate grievances of people?
Don't make a point and then change the topic so
you can get away with it. Your government, NATO
supported Al-Qaeda. In 2011 and '12, when I went
to the Western media and said that Al-Qaeda is
fighting in Syria, they said, these are conspiracy
theories. This is nonsense. Well, later on we saw
WikiLeaks, whose head is now in jail, the most
famous political prisoner in the world in London.
WikiLeaks said that according to Jake Sullivan,
the current US national security adviser,
he sent an email to Hillary Clinton, the head of
the State Department at that time, that in Syria
Al-Qaeda is on our side. No, it's your government
and your government sent out the worst murderers
in human history and in contemporary history.
Then we have the US Defense Intelligence Agency
document of 2012. We said a Salafist entity —
regional countries allied to the United States
are trying to create a Salafist entity between
Syria and Iraq. Well, who? What is that? What
was that entity? It was ISIS. And then General
Flynn at that time said that the, that they
were determined and the United States allowed for
that entity to be created. Then we had John Kerry…
OK, you're clearly not answering. You're clearly
not interested in answering any questions.
No, no, no. No no. Let me finish...
...You're not interested in
answering any questions...
...Let me finish. Let me finish...
...This is not a lecture, Dr. Marandi.
...No, let me finish.
I asked you some questions…
John Kerry...
You don't want to answer them...
Oh, yes, it is. John Kerry said
in a private conversation...
You're afraid. You're afraid.
You don't want to answer questions.
You're afraid. Go on, ask your question.
My question is...
...No, you're afraid.
...My question is — afraid of you? Really?...
...Kerry said we let ISIS advance on Damascus.
There could have been a different
approach by the government to this unrest,
couldn't there? Like the one suggested by five
leading Iranian economists earlier this month,
who say the authorities should listen to the
demonstrators and prepare for fundamental change.
Is there anybody inside the government who is
preparing for fundamental change, in your view?
First of all, when — going back to the previous
question, the guards and whoever and anyone else
who spoke about sedition, they were not talking
about protesters. So don't try to twist their
words. They were talking about those groups
that are funded by the United States in Iraqi
Kurdistan. That they have military camps there
and they carry out operations in Iran. They're
talking about those organizations alongside the
no man's land in Pakistan, Baluchistan, that are
funded by your government or the United States
and its allies and carry out operations in Iran.
They're talking about those MEK terrorists that
your governments allow to function across Europe,
that have killed many thousands of Iranians
and acted as foot soldiers for Saddam Hussein,
who are active in Iran by their own
admission. So they're talking about that
sedition. So don't twist what he had to say.
All right. All right. You've, you've had
your say. You've had your lecture...
With regards to the economists and others...
...You've flung around all the accusations...
...Yeah. Of course.
…You haven't provided any evidence at all.
Let's talk, if we may, about the nuclear
issue, because you've been an adviser to the
government on the nuclear issue. In your view,
is this the end of the road for negotiations?
We have the US saying that they simply
don't believe that Iran is prepared to do
what's necessary to make the deal happen.
In your view, is that the end of
the road for the negotiations?
Well, Tim, who left the deal? Who violated the
deal? Obama violated the deal when Iran was
carrying out all of its commitments. Then Trump
tore up the deal when Iran was carrying out all
its commitments. Then Biden continued to pursue
Trump's policies. So it wasn't Iran's fault.
Iran began negotiating to make sure the loopholes
that existed, that existed in the past after 2015,
were removed so that the United States could
not cheat Iran again. They negotiated hard,
gained many concessions. Finally, on the last
day of negotiations in Vienna, the EU gave a
text that met a lot of Iran's key demands. And the
Iranians took it home, they gave their ideas about
some of the problems that need to be resolved.
And Joseph [sic] Borrell admitted — the US ally
Joseph [sic] Borrell admitted that the Iranian
demands were reasonable. We thought at that time
we had a deal, but the United States delayed
and then gave a response that was obviously
intended to push things back. Probably, we thought
back then, because of the November elections. So,
the problem is not the United States. And by
the way, Iran, the European, the Europeans
and the Americans were constantly saying that
it's almost too late. The Iranian nuclear program
is crossing a threshold beyond this particular
date. We can no longer continue negotiations,
but they're all gone now. What happened? It was
obvious. They were lying. They knew that Iran's
nuclear program was peaceful...
Dr. Marandi, the UN...
…They knew that Iran was not developing a
bomb, but it was all psychological warfare.
The U.N. says you've still not provided
credible explanations for the presence
of uranium at three locations that were never
declared. And you just say it's time to close
the false file. Do you enjoy playing these
kind of games with the international community?
Well, Tim, first of all, it's not the
international community, it's Western
countries. You are not the international
community. Your garden is only a small part
of the international community. The Iranians
have said that we're prepared to respond to
all of the questions. But the problem is that the
IAEA, the IAEA has a board of governors that is
dominated by Western countries. And the head of
the IAEA is someone that's always in the Western
camp. The previous head of the IAEA, when he
wanted to get elected — And let's go back to
WikiLeaks. According to WikiLeaks documents,
he told the Americans, If you put me in power,
I will be in your camp on all major issues. So
the Iranians are saying, take away the politics
and bring in the technical experts, and the issues
can easily be resolved. These issues that you're
claiming were given by the Israeli regime to the
IAEA. And these issues go back 20-some years ago
when the Iranian nuclear program was taking
baby steps. It was nothing compared to what
it was today, what it is today. So, we all know
that the whole process is politicized, but the
Iranians are more than willing to solve the issue
if the Americans are determined to have a deal.
You said you were asked why Iran is enriching
uranium at 60% levels. What the IAEA said, levels
that are reached only by countries that are making
nuclear bombs. And you say Iran does that in order
to get leverage in the talks. Let's call that what
it really is. It's not leverage. It's a threat...
Yes, of course.
...pure and simple. It's a threat,
isn't it? Pure and simple. If you don't
get what you want, you'll build a bomb.
Despite all the assurances that you've
given that you don't intend to do that.
No, Tim, you know, do you know what a threat is?
A threat is when your governments say all options
are on the table. A threat is when your country
is, your government threatened to kill our people.
That's a threat. Enriching at 60%
is leverage. What your governments
do are threats. And they carry it out in
different countries. They destroyed Iraq,
they destroyed Libya, they sanctioned
Venezuela. Your government steals money
from the Venezuelan people and starves them
and then says the government in Venezuela,
they mismanage. So you strangle people and
then you ask, why can't they breathe? No,
your government threatens other countries and
your governments carry out those threats. So we
take those seriously. But no, on the other
hand, when the Iranians enrich at 60%...
So it's always the other
governments that are at fault...
…they are only saying it to tell the Europeans
and the Americans to sit down and get serious.
Dr. Marandi. Much controversy…
Yes. It is your government. It is
your government that's been...
It's always everybody else...
...harassing our people for over 100 years.
...Always, always, always. Much controversy.
No, it's not everyone else.
It's Western governments.
It's always somebody else.
It's not Asian, it is not Asia,
it is not Latin America, it is not Africa. It
is your governments, it is NATO governments.
It's the evil West. OK, we got the point, it’s...
…Don't pretend that you're
the international community.
...It's the evil West. Much controversy
briefly over the last few days about...
You can call it what you like.
...about the reports of Iranian drones being
used by Russia in its war with Ukraine.
Strenuous denials from Iranian officials. But
the Ukrainians themselves have identified the
devices as Shahed 136 drones. How ignorant does
Iran think the rest of the world really is to try
and claim that they didn't give them to Russia?
Don't, don't, don't, don't call yourself the rest
of the world. I'm, first of all, I'm not in the
foreign ministry. But a number of things, Tim.
And I, I speak on behalf of myself. Your
governments lied. You advanced westwards. You
advance NATO eastwards to the Russian border. Your
governments carried out a coup in Ukraine. Your
governments supported right-wing fascists like the
Azov Battalion, which in the Western media it was
discussed. They were saying before the events
this year that they, that this is a big problem
in Ukraine, and they killed 15 or 16,000 ethnic
Russians in the Donbass region and in other parts
of eastern Ukraine. Your governments provoked
Russia, your governments allowed this to happen.
You've gone through the list and you've
swallowed Russian propaganda hook,
line and sinker. Dr. Marandi,
it's been good to have you on
Conflict Zone. Thank you very much indeed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm a Russian propagandist.
I'm a Russian propagandist. I've been gassed
twice by your government, the government that
pays you. So I think, and your government's done
that in the 20th century before, apparently.
Right. Thanks. Thanks so much for your time.
Thank you.